m
il se
ces chemins
ambiance diplomatique et donc
protocolaire sur le front de mer de
saint denis la communauté indienne
inaugure ce centre culturel aux lieux
pleins d'espoir l'espoir bonne chose
pour se sentir mieux comme ça ça permet
pour les jeunes mais de se rattacher dû
se raccrocher à leur culture à leur pays
d'origine
foi de livres concernant vanessa la
culture je connais beaucoup mais pas par
une occasion de
de s'enrichir là c'est une porte ouverte
pour nous petit réunionnais qui connaît
pas l'aisne mais tu descends quand même
de nos origines sont indienne à venir la
réunion c'est l'ouverture
ah oui c'est sûr nature et on est déjà
enlevé depuis très longtemps nous on est
réunionnais
avec un tiers de la population
réunionnaise en lien direct avec l'inde
entre la culture la gastronomie ou
encore les ntic l'inde et partout avec
ces expositions sont lazaret ou encore
séjourner pour la non violence
le conseil départemental devait
s'associer à cet événement
la france aime l'inde
lévis la fraternité franco indienne
d'une visite d'état loin de passer
inaperçue car c'est bien l'ouverture à
ce continent que le ministre qui jure
avoir des échanges culturels éducatifs
et entre les étudiants parce que les
gens de ce pays ont beaucoup de liens
avec le peuple indien et ils sont très
nombreux
voilà les trois grands champs des
changes qui ont peu à voir et nous vous
pouvez aussi avoir des relations entre
les deux régions et que je pense qu'il y
avait beaucoup de gros dans ciel dans ce
domaine il y a beaucoup de trajets entre
l'indre et maurice et il nous souhaitons
aussi lié le vol sur ce territoire
c'est une partie du programme des
changes touristique
je pense que dans les relations qui
lient la réunion et l'inde
il peut y avoir des échanges économiques
il ya beaucoup de potentiel dans les
relations économiques et touristiques
à la différence de nos voisins
mauriciens c'est la première fois qu'un
haut dignitaire indien passe par notre
île les 10 heures passées sur notre
département auront été chargé cet acte
donne une nouvelle perspective à la
coopération et notamment pour les
étudiants réunionnais